Look—it's changing color.
It's changing color...
instantly.
It's pretty amazing.
Oh, here we go.
[laughter]
This is six months of stress.
This side up... great.
Okay, so let's just slowly unsnake it.
Okay, let's just roll it.
Here we go.
Great.
We can slowly start to move it...
Yeah, so we get that corner orientated here,
which that'll be great.
That's about right.
Right?
Today what we're doing is we're just unrolling
and unfolding the whole canopy.
As you can see it's massive.
It will fill the entire courtyard.
And in prep for tomorrow, when we start to
take these edges and tails and begin to ratchet
and connect to the courtyard walls.
We successfully removed the supports, so the
mast and the ropes are working together in
tension and compression and standing on their
own.
And what we're about to do—we have the large
canopy prepped.
We're going to start with the north wall,
and we're going to start to make connections
in that corner.
And then we're going to move it to tower one
and make connections to the tension ring.
We'll unzip the zipper and then bring it around
and zip it up, and then we'll make connections
along the the southwest wall here, and then
slowly work our way around to the southeast
wall, and then eventually to tower two, and
just stitch our way around.
Is it knitted or crocheted?
It's knitted—digitally knitted.
Wow.
Yeah, every single one.
And then they're finished and sewn together,
so they're digitally knitted first and then
finished.
So the forces are actually carried through
the webbing.
So this—you can see, Klaus—we cut away
the supports, the temporary supports, so this
is now free-standing.
How tall is it?
Almost 43 feet.
Wow.
Yeah.
So ambitious.
I love the ambition.
It's insane.
[laughter]
Move it with the webbing, not the knit.
Nice!
Yeah, this thing's heavier than it looks!
Five hundred pounds.